ARTHEL: CHRISTINA COLEMAN LIVE
IN LOS ANGELES, THANK YOU.
ERIC.
ERIC: ARTHEL, NOW TO THE CRISIS
IN THE SOUTHERN BORDER, VICE
PRESIDENT HARRIS STILL TAKING
HEAT FOR TRIP TO EL PASO, TEXAS
ON FRIDAY AND CRITICS FAULTING
HER FOR NOT VISITING THE
EPICENTER THAT HAPPENS TO BE
HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY IN THE
RIO GRANDE VALLEY AND FOR TAKING
3 MONTHS TO GO TO THE WORD NEAR
-- BORDER IN THE FIRST PLACE AND
SHE'S FOCUSING IN THE ROOTS AND
THAT'S WHY SHE WENT TO GUATEMALA
AND MEXICO CITY.
OFFICIALS SAY THAT MIGRANT SURGE
IS NOT LETTING UP DESPITE THE
SCORCHING HEAT THAT'S CAUSED
SOME DEATHS OF MIGRANTS AND THE
OTHER DANGERS THEY FACE, ALEX
HOGAN LIVE NOW ON THE BORDER IN
MISSION, TEXAS WHICH IS IN THE
RIO GRANDE VALLEY AREA WHERE THE
BULK OF MIGRANTS HAVE BEEN
ASKING FOR ASYLUM AND GIVING
THEMSELVES UP.
THE BULK OF THEM HAVE APPEARED.
ALEX IS STANDING BY NEAR WHAT
HAS BEEN PART OF THE OLD FENCE.
HI, ALEX.
ALEX: HI, ERIC, THIS IS PART OF
THE UNFINISHED BORDER WALL.
IT APPEARS THERE'S SOME
CONSTRUCTION UNDERWAY LIKELY
MAINTENANCE OR WHAT APPEARS TO
BE MAINTENANCE BUT, AGAIN, THIS
IS THE BUSIEST SECTION OF THE
BORDER, SO FAR 271,000 MIGRANTS
HAVE CROSSED THROUGH THE RIO
GRANDE VALLEY.
NOW THAT'S ABOUT THE SIZE, THE
POPULATION SIZE OF MADISON,
WISCONSIN.
MOST OF THE MIGRANTS ARRIVED
FROM THE NORTHERN TRIANGLE
COUNTRIES SAYING THEY ARE
FLEEING POVERTY AND PERSECUTION.
TOMORROW HHS SECRETARY JAVIER
BECERRA WILL VISIT AN EMERGENCY
INTAKE SITE AT FORT BLISS, TEXAS
CURRENTLY UNDER MICROSCOPE FOR
POOR CONDITIONS FOR CHILDREN,
SOME OF WHOM ARE REPORTEDLY
UNDER SUPERVISION TO PREVENT
SELF-HARM.
>> ADVOCATES HAVE DOCUMENTED
INADEQUATE CONDITIONS IN THE
FACILITY AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WORKING TO
IMPROVE CONDITIONS.
ALEX: VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA
HARRIS DID VISIT WILL PAS WHERE
SHE CALLED OUT THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION FOR STARTING
SEPARATION POLICY.
>> EL PASO IS A WONDERFUL
COMMUNITY, IT'S A VIBRANT BORDER
COMMUNITY, IMPORTANT CITY IN
TEXAS, BUT IT'S NOT THE
EPICENTER OF THE CRISIS.
THE EPICENTER OF THE CRISIS AS
YOU SAID IS 800 MILES AWAY IN
THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY.
ALEX: HERE IN THE RIO GRANDE
VALLEY THE THREAT, OF COURSE, OF
CHILDREN HARMING THEMSELVES IS
VERY REAL AFTER THE JOURNEY THEY
HAVE BEEN THROUGH.
NOW AMONG ONE OF THOSE POLICIES
PUT IN PLACE TO PREVENT JUST
THAT, CHILDREN USUALLY WILL
ASKED TO REMOVE THEIR SHOE LACES
BEFORE THEY ARE TAKEN ONTO A BUS
AND TAKEN TO FACILITY AND
COUNSELORS AT THE CENTERS ARE
ALSO AVAILABLE.
ERIC.
ERIC: ALL RIGHT, ALEX, ON